bonsoir marc antoine pellin série là
j'ai rien à faire non c'est pas si vous
pouvez me lancer en sébastien ouais mais
j'ai pas dit j'ai pas de seuil et
maléfices nous lancer juste vous dire
qu'il ya patrick sébastien cas-là
d'accord mais si vous êtes qui pour me
donner des ordres
je sais ce que je veux si j'ai envie de
penser que quelqu'un donne et si j'en ai
pensé jean claude van damme et moi il
paraît qu'à patrick sébastien qui est
venu nous voir c'est génial c'est chaud
est un bon jour quelqu'un c'est légitime
de ma [ __ ] quand la fête et ce soir je
reçois delson monfort a commenté bob
anderson et bien écoutez mon bateau inc
force m'est de constater qu il règne ici
une ambiance ouais c'est super c'est
génial
et ce soir il ya aussi roselyne bachelot
qui va avec
comment ça va marc au bout ne maîtrise
que non je dois vous dire que je suis
vraiment qui monte plus ça c'est super g
si on a aussi le maître cérémonie des
césars edouard baer et comment tu te
sens mon doudou
mais je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de
bonnes ou mauvaises manières de se
sentir
parce que si je devais résumer ouais
c'est super g et au site est le nouveau
pensionnaire qui est là mais je la
décris proposant j'adore c'est jean marc
et gestes pas la clock est là comment et
comment ils sommes au journal des coûts
non piratés cardiaque à mardi sauf que
toi c'est pas de joliette
c'est johnny brodard
thomas et homophobes ça ouais mais la
kippa ce jour n'a que sa maman mon cul
par l'homophobie génère aussi montrer le
regard du temps qui passe et qui
rappelle aux gens non
tu peux pas dire ça tue pas dire du bien
de quelqu'un pour changer si jadot une
aura j'adore son émission de télé je
veux ressembler sur une radio
j'adore c'est ça j'adore ça je n'avais
on va dire ça jean marc
sinon j'aime bien aussi le nom unis
bosque a vraiment comme le bon vin
pourquoi s'améliore avec l'âge non
content t'as pas trop mal à la france
c'est comme un musée marriages tu sais
que tout le monde attend jan map
merci beaucoup merci je voulais c'est
beaucoup